so to get into this let's talk a little
bit about the basics of how the web
works I'm going really back to the
initial conception of the web in its
most basic form the web is a way to
publish documents alright so if I wanted
to publish document what I would do is
upload it to a web server and then that
servers gonna host it and distribute it
out to my audience
right and that's the publishing flow now
of course the big deal with the web
early on was the fact that you linked
from document to document right but the
hypertext that's the big idea the server
was just sort of an implementation
detail it's how we did it but that
wasn't necessarily the key of this thing
the key was that it was the web
documents link to each other and without
a complex top down a hierarchy you can
be a free and open publishing platform
alright and that worked pretty well and
it got popular after a while we started
want to want to do things we couldn't do
originally on the web we wanted to have
things like Wikipedia where you could
edit the page inline we want to have
things like Twitter where you can put a
little status updates outright so deal
with that we started to put an
application code and I think my
computers froze on in a second there we
go
started to put our application code into
the server and along with that
application code we began to put
databases onto the server alright and
this is how we began to have more
dynamic behaviors on the web and we
moved away from the web 1.0 conception
of documents and links to the web 2.0
idea which is that we're going to have
rich applications running on top of the
web platform but these applications live
in the server your application code your
database your source of truth all going
to exist inside the server and these
computers with their web browsers are
what you call a thin client they're just
rendering a UI and the core of that
application is up on the server now the
good thing is that works really well
the cloud has been in a lot of ways an
enormous step forward for computing both
for developers and for end-users
everybody benefits from the fact that it
is always available these servers are
kept online all the time there man had
sent managed centrally and they update
automatically right so you don't have to
go and update individual computers
everybody's just on the same page
handles a lot of data scales up really
well as an end user I don't need to
worry about synchronizing my devices or
losing a hard drive because I can just
reconnect my account on a new device
there are a lot of benefits to the cloud
so we got to the point where we started
to say well you know what let's just do
everything this way right so here we are
now with these enormous servers up at
the top and it's gotten to the point
that if you're going to do something
that even in its nature is a
peer-to-peer transaction like for
instance sending a file from one
computer to the other well how are you
going to do it of course you're gonna
use a service right you're going to
stick it on Dropbox or Google Drive and
that's how you're gonna get the file
over to somebody so we have what I would
call a an architectural monoculture
everything is done client-server
regardless of the actual needs of your
application all right well what's the
problem if it works it works with the
big deal well first of all the answer to
that can't just be that you don't like
Facebook politics are a good reason to
set yourself out on a project but you
actually need to have deliverables right
what are we trying to fix well if you
talk to web users nowadays probably the
number one thing they'll say about the
web if you're asking them what they
don't like about it is that it's a
little bit creepy and that you don't own
your data you don't own your network
let's drill into these individually
first of all for whatever reason the web
has never evolved a way for users users
to send information from one device to
another with complete in to in secrecy
if you're really advanced you can figure
it out using something like PGP but for
the most part all the data we send goes
in the clear through a third party so
we're talking about emails and we're
talking about documents we're talking
about office information right
electrical properties going into the
cloud and a lot of cases it's sitting in
a warehouse somewhere in plain text now
a part of our obligation is software
engineers is to protect users data and
in that regard we're not doing a great
job this is the security limitation in
the way that we're doing things and we
ought to move past it there's also a an
element of a lack of trust I think that
this sets his users at this point our
custom to the fact that they expect to
have their data mined and that is going
to eventually cause our user base to
lose trust in what we do and that is
just something that we should not allow
all right next problem lack of modify
ability so show of hands who here
recently has had a pull request merged
into Facebook nobody right you can't do
it
the lack of end-user modify ability is a
freeze on the amount of innovation we
can use or put into work on the web
right if users can't solve their own
problems then they're gonna have to wait
for companies to do it for them there's
not a whole lot of a fine grained
control about what your experience is
like on Facebook everybody gets the same
thing all right so we're losing
opportunities to do interesting things
or to make decisions for ourselves I'm a
hacker I want to be able to edit my
source code somewhat complementary to
that is a lack of ownership of your
actual data all the data is being stored
into a database in somebody's server so
even if I did have all the source code
to Facebook and I deployed it on some
server somewhere I still wouldn't be
able to message my friends or send out a
friend request or see their fees because
actually all of Facebook is stored on
the internal data structures and the
internal data networks of Facebook it's
not a federated system so they would
have to complete the architect to
support that they're not going to and so
users lack ownership of their data they
lack ownership of their networks and
they lack ownership of their code so why
talk about getting away from a
client-server monoculture the reason is
that we can improve the privacy of the
web
and we can also improve the ownership of
the online experience for people talking
about this a little more dryly and
specifically you could say it's an
architectural deficiency we've put a
whole lot of work into making the
client-server model work really well
tons of resources and it's been doing a
great job but the period of pure story
on the web is pretty anemic now broadly
speaking you can think of the web as an
application platform for networked
applications all right if you're going
to have a lot of users working together
you use the web and so it would make
sense that we have not just one design
for how our networking is done but some
flexibility of this then not only can
you do client-server but you can also
have peer-to-peer architectures or even
better a hybrid of the two to match
exactly what you're trying to accomplish
with your application so we want some
flexibility in how this is done all
right so that's the why that's where
we're coming from with this project
let's talk about what we've actually
been doing broadly speaking the mandate
has been if we integrate peer-to-peer
networking into the web what do we get
out of it what kind of features can we
start to stick into the browser and so
what we've done is we've take an
electron which is basically a wrapper
around chromium and use that to create
our own Fork of Chrome we're not the
only people doing this right now
brave is a browser that's pretty well
known that's run by Brendan Eich exact
same story there's a couple others as
well but for us the focus is on a
specific kind of peer-to-peer networking
now we're not talking about WebRTC and
we're not talking about blockchains the
kind of peer-to-peer network we're using
is a variation of BitTorrent it's called
the DAT project all right very similar
to BitTorrent we kind of it's like a
BitTorrent 2.0 the same basic principles
are at work so if you have a bunch of
users accessing certain swarm of data
they're gonna Rijos
those files and give pieces out all
right so you're sharing bandwidth and as
a result it scales automatically and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second
the way that we are using this is as a
drop-in replacement for HTTP okay and
we're now getting rid of HTTP but
mechanically we've added a protocol that
functionally is exactly the same as HTTP
but it's peer-to-peer and as a result
you have this automatic bandwidth
scaling because users share bandwidth
but also any device can become a server
in an ad hoc fashion I'm gonna use this
laptop make it a server if I wanted to
use a mobile device all right anything
also cloud servers as usual can access
the network and serve on it as well so
let's go back to our diagram with how
publishing works on the web in our model
rather than I want to publish my
document here or publish some media or a
JSON file or something I'm gonna do it
directly I'm not gonna use a server to
do it I'm gonna be the server and
somebody that's requesting it will
download it directly from my device okay
now real quick show of hands who
everybody here raise your hand if you
are familiar with how BitTorrent works
by the basic level you've used it may be
okay so like 2/3 of the audience okay
so we'll step through exactly what
happens the person on the right they're
the first recipient of the website that
we've created and we've served it
directly from our device now somebody
new comes along a third party and they
want to download this website what
happens is that rather than just one
server my computer that published the
site in the first place we now have two
servers we have my computer and the
computer that downloaded it from me and
the third party could receive those
files from either of us or both of us
and this compounds over time so that as
new people come into the network they
add in their resources to host files for
other people and it scales up and up and
up like that now participation is not
permanent it's going to depend on how we
tweak it but the way it works right now
for a short period after visiting a
website you will automatically riho stit
give back to the person that gave you
that content I have an altruistic
concept
that we call this the swarm and it's
kind of like a distributed server it's
like all of us are working together to
comprise one server logically the swarm
has some pretty interesting end results
most of them have to do with cost
because you are sharing bandwidth with
the network automatically you don't have
to pay the burden pay the cost of all
that outbound bandwidth that's actually
one of the most pricey resources for
hosting online it's about 10 times as
expensive as as disk space and if you're
trying to get to a world where users are
able to independently publish websites
or content this actually gets pretty
important because you can imagine
somebody makes a video it goes viral
you're talking about a lot of bandwidth
if you just had an HTTP server at
somebody's home even if they actually
managed to handle all those requests
we're talking YouTube kind of scale here
you're talking a lot of requests a lot
of bandwidth being used they're gonna
have to pay for it probably depending on
what their ISP situation is like so the
cost reduction is actually an important
enabler for making it possible for you
to publish information that gets popular
and not have to rely on a really big
vendor like YouTube to actually shoulder
the cost of that bandwidth right the
network makes it cheaper the other thing
that it does and that I think is
actually little more interesting is it
makes it really really cheap to allocate
new websites okay because then this
network each website rather be being
addressed by an IP address like we
normally do you're talking to a computer
instead what we use are public keys
these are cryptographically addressed
websites so you can allocate a new
website simply by generating a new
random key it's very easy to mint a new
website and you can make as many as you
want
and this really shifts the way that you
think about how you build an application
because now traditionally you would
think you got your client server you got
a server somewhere and you're gonna put
a database up there and that's how
you're gonna publish information
well now it's very very cheap to
allocate new websites so why not instead
just create a new
website and start putting the user data
into that website anytime you have a new
user account create a new website for it
and start sticking the data on there as
JSON files it really kind of shifts up
the way that you think about how an
application has to be built I'll step
through it and a little more detail here
before we get into the mechanics of
building an app the first thing I wanted
to make really clear is that it's a file
based data model it's almost kind of
UNIX II we're going back to the idea
everything is a file all the data in the
network is a file as a result of the
protocol when you go to a site you can
actually ask the browser to show me the
file listing and it'll take you into an
explorer kind of interface and I'll show
you in a demo in a second what this
looks like but you can actually get a
full listing of the application or the
website that you're visiting you can see
all the files you can open up the
folders and see what's in there and you
can read and so this is at the core of
it it's all just files and it's like a
bunch of static websites really in
addition to the Det protocol for
browsing around there's a Web API that
we've added which allows you to read
these files and write the files to get
the file listings and also do things
like watch for changes on the network
which ends up being really valuable if
you want to make real time responsive
applications that sit there and watch
these sites for newly published
information right now I'm hitting you
with a lot of concepts but we're about
to wrap it all together at the moment
the way this works is when you create a
site you become the author nobody else
can change it is bound to your device
all right so the wrap this all together
let's go by an example suppose we wanted
to make a Twitter clone traditional way
to do that is we create a website and a
web server put it up in the cloud
somewhere get a database a user that
wants to get onto our site would access
the server and would say hey create a
new profile for me the server would say
fine it would create a new record for
you in its database and then it would
publish that information by merit of
serving to clients that asks for the
information that's the traditional model
all right so how would we do a
peer-to-peer version of our Twitter
clone what we're gonna do instead is
we'll ask our application hey please
make a user profile for me and instead
of talking to a server it's just gonna
create a new website for you create a
new pure site and inside of that site
it's gonna write your information as
JSON files now the code for this is on
your device alright there's no server
involved this is a peer-to-peer web site
all the code comes down to your device
it decides to mint this new website for
you to store all of your user data and
now the distribution mechanism is
through the peer-to-peer network and
what you're gonna find is that the
peer-to-peer network is sort of like
your new database through the files is
how you're going to read and write data
so now this is showing it graphically
here you got your peer-to-peer
application here and that's the our
Twitter clone and it mints the user
profile side where we're going to put
our posts we're gonna put our lights
we're gonna put our friends any
information about what I'm doing on our
little Twitter clone it's gonna live on
that user profile side and all of this
is happening on my device so we don't
even have to be connected to the network
at this point right because we're just
writing files onto my in down to my my
laptop here and then making it available
on on the peer-to-peer network and we
can do that later
right so the writing of the files could
happen whether or not we have an
internet connection and we can
distribute the files later when the
internet comes back on so here's what
that profile JSON might look like it's
pretty straightforward
I got my name I've got my bio I've got
my avatar my picture and also I've got a
list of who I'm following right and
included in there is some information
about who it is and a URL for them for
their personal peer-to-peer site right
it's just using peer-to-peer sites and
using files so now you might ask let's
make a listing of people that I know
right I'm let's say I'm following three
people and I want to get a nice list of
all of our faces and all of our BIOS and
things like that well first we'll say
let's render mine so we'll access my
profile JSON that's already on my
computer so we can just read it easy
and then we've got these three people on
following so for each of them all find
their peer-to-peer site on the network
and I'll download the profile that JSON
for each of them right it's called it
got all the information I need and when
will aggregate that information into a
table maybe in memory or we can write it
to a disk if we want to persist it so
that we can don't have to access the
network in the future and then rendering
is pretty simple just like you would be
doing this in a normal application
you're just gonna iterate to your table
and you're gonna pull the data out and
put it on the page right and this
pattern has worked well enough that
we've actually standardized it into a
database that lives in user land which
we call ingest DB so here you have these
peer-to-peer web sites and I'm showing
here for the first time a little glimpse
of these public key addresses this is a
shortened version it's actually 64
characters long of these URLs these have
files on them and Zoey and Jess TB says
okay I know that on the post folder if
there's a JSON file inside the post
folder that's like a Twitter post to
scan for those and when you find them
ingest them eat them up and put them
into a table for us and we actually
store that table inside of index dB so
that we can run nice fast queries
against them right then let's say you
want to make a change to one of those
posts or you want to make a new post
well you're just gonna write a file a
new post post slash three JSON to put
the new post in there it'll ingest its
way back into our table alright and this
is the data model that we've been using
for this system to build applications
and I'll show you an example application
that does just this but the idea again
is that it's nothing but files just like
in the good old days of UNIX files are
at its core when you have a record you
just write a JSON file and that gets
published on these peer-to-peer web
sites so okay that's that's that's the
data model we've been working with and
you know what let's just get these two
things I'll get to this later let's just
get to it straight to a demo so you can
all see what I'm talking about here all
right this is beaker this is version oh
wait it's not yet released
let me move it down a little bits we're
not cut off there all right
so y'all are going to be seeing some
stuff that it not many people have seen
yet because this is all still in
development so we may hit some bugs when
they hit some crashes let's hold our
breath
now the basic browsing experience is
more or less what you would expect you
can go to traditional websites you can
create multiple tabs you know we're
doing our best to sort of keep the
expectations of how the web works let's
go over to our web page here and the
first thing sort of unique is that we
have this period of pure version
available tag right so we have a
mechanism of being able to see when
there's a DAT version of a site so why
don't we go ahead and go to it now all
you're going to notice changing if
things are working correctly is this
right here the protocol is gonna change
but we have the exact same content being
posted on HTTPS that we do on the
peer-to-peer dat version so all right
there we go
yeah there we go so this is exactly like
you would expect out of the web like I
say it's a drop-in replacement for HTTP
so you can navigate around you use HTML
you have embedded assets links and
things like that it works completely as
you would expect where you start to see
some more interesting things as over
here in the top right first of all
normally there's a couple of people Rijo
stting free hosting the signage to see
that there's not any but there's your
pure account right there that's how many
people are on the network I guess I'm
lucky I already had this downloaded on
my computer and save permanently so I
didn't have a problem accessing it we've
also got this control here where you can
start to take advantage of how this
peer-to-peer system works where you can
go and view the files back when we go
ahead and do that so here we're inside
of our files Explorer and there is that
index.html right there and we can just
browse around and see all the assets
involved for this website
okay so again it's all just files yeah
go ahead binaries for our downloads oh
right right
we're not distributing it on yet but at
some point we absolutely will put it on
there ya know it still can work on
demand so you can actually download
subsets of a website individual files
you don't have to download the entire
website when you go to a new site okay
so it's a good question but thankfully
no you don't have to download it every
time now related to that we also have
this control here which controls whether
or not your Rijo sling aside at all and
this is a way for us to get into this
idea of socially kind of altruistically
giving away bandwidth and helping each
other keep your stuff online and so this
is a specific control usually it starts
out over here you go to a site you're
not gonna realize it you'll you'll
temporarily give up some bandwidth but
you're not gonna keep it online but you
can adjust the slider and say yeah I'll
give them a day you know I'll give back
a little bit or maybe I want to give a
whole month so I'll give a whole month
and that kind of gets the timer going if
we open it back up and let us know how
much time is left on that time we get a
month still right so that's a really key
part of what we think is interesting
about this is that you can start to
really contribute to each other actual
resources right this is kind of a little
bit more cohesive a little bit more like
we're helping each other out it will
stay in to the swarm and watch for
updates so the likelihood of you getting
stale is pretty small all right now I'm
gonna cheat over here and look at my
demo outline Yeah right why don't I go
ahead and create one of these pure sites
so again very easy to publish directly
from a device and that allows us to have
this cool button right here in the menu
just to create a new website
the sitter face is a little janky we're
still working on it but let's go ahead
and make our PDX node b-sides alright
alright it just dumped us into our
little file explorer and we're looking
at our site here once we're a little
crowded for screen real estate I
apologize for that but here's the site
that I created and by default it sticks
in this JSON file which is a manifest
file it's including information that I
just entered in as well as the URL now
let's let's stick in some files here
let's bring in a picture let's say so
how about I jump over to pictures folder
and alright some cute cats that's cool
so open up the URL here and I could take
this URL give that to anybody on the
network and they'll be able to download
it directly for my computer file sharing
builder I did now you'll notice it's a
pretty enormous URL we got there that's
the 64 character public key all right we
have the ability to use DNS which is
exactly what you saw earlier so you
don't have to look at those ugly keys
for the most part what we do is we just
shorten it so it's not too bad to look
at and you know we'll see maybe people
don't care at all but ok this is a
website too so let's jump over to the
root resource and see what we get
alright the file listing you would
expect that out of a website without an
index.html so I prepared an index tell
you HTML let me pull that in all right
I'm gonna refresh the page there we go
even got some marquee on there so I do
all that to demonstrate that this all
works very much as you expect out of the
web oh there we go there's a broken
interface let's see if we can do that
all right that's good enough I don't
know if you all can quite see that but
this is just HTML we're just doing an
image tag right there referring to a
file on our website right soup
familiar stuff alright back to the cheat
sheet
alright we got another application let's
get into a little bit that data model I
was talking about about how applications
are able to share data in the first
place to do that I'm going to open up an
application that might crash us so let's
give a shot cool can we survive this is
a code editor that we built originally
we built this code editor to be a part
of the browser itself but we kind of
realized maybe that's not the best idea
was getting a little bit large so we
moved it out into userland so now this
actually lives in as an application this
is a peer to peer application okay and
what it's going to do is use web api's
to read and write files and provide a
nice kind of code under experience a
little bit like a light ide and in fact
we're using the monaco editor which is
what vs code uses so it's actually a
pretty nice piece of software so let's
open up our site that we just created
there alright there it is right there's
our little PDX node set while we open it
up again now let's make a change it's
you know that marquee was bad ID let's
get rid of that and add a few more
exclamation points all right and I hit
control s now it's gonna have to ask
permission because it's about to modify
another side on my device so of course
you want to ask permission for that but
I'll go ahead and allow it over here and
refresh there you have right so it's all
kind of like a universal web file system
that we're working with okay should be
pretty intuitive now let's see if you
know we have a live reloading tool and
they see where that's at yeah all right
this may work you can see a lightning
bolt here to indicate what I did is I
just turned on live reloading through
our tools up here it should be possible
should see this thing reload without me
having to touch anything well that's in
question there all right there went the
think about that live reloading to your
question earlier is that that works over
the network because whenever you enter
into the swarm you're gonna sit there
and you're gonna put out a UDP packet
once every I think five seconds not a
whole lot of bandwidth but you're
sitting there asking anybody got
something new and by and large somebody
nobody'll say anything but if there is
something new it'll come down and the
browser can actually recognize that if
you got live reloading on they'll reload
the page for you just a kind of a neat
thing that we found
hey we could do that you know we have
access to that information so we threw
it in alright one other kind of cool
thing about this data model can be
demonstrated with the WYSIWYG II the way
you see is what you wiki now only can
you edit other websites with these api's
you can actually do self mutation which
may actually be a really bad idea but we
did it anyway so let me make a copy of
this site now forking is just like in
github you can actually go to any site
you want and say fork this thing for me
you're gonna download all the files
you're going to create a new site copy
the files over just like that you now
have a version of the site that you can
edit all right putting stuff in people's
control that's the idea so let's do PD X
node wiki create our fork this up and
fast all right done at the edit button
and let's get some cool Styles on there
hit the Save button and we did it we
just mutated the site using its own code
using the WYSIWYG controls inside of
there we just wrote to the source code
of it and change the content so actually
you know we jump over to the File
Explorer and look at the index.html and
not gonna be able to know well I
apologize I went and broke our view
source tool so we can't see it but
inside of there you would find that we
actually just modified the index.html
just wrote directly to itself why not we
might at some point have to rein that
back we're not really sure what the
security profile is something like that
it's gonna be but for now we figured
it's it's kind of cool makes it easy to
make nice
self modifiable websites for a wiki like
that it's actually a pretty handy use
case all right now let's bring it all
together with one last idea earlier I
was talking about the JSON records and
sitting there and watching them and
ingest d-beam
well after writing that for applications
we actually realized that we wanted to
put some application features in the
browser itself so ingest DB is inside
the browser as well and we've used that
to implement some application sawyer's
and the browser starting with the
ability to create public bookmarks and
apologies to the guy from pinboard but
we've just been ripping off all these
good ideas we've got tags on the
bookmarks
we've got notes so you can say why you
bookmarked it in the first place and you
can see here I'm following my co-founder
Terah Bansal and I can narrow down to
the bookmarks that she's made public so
each of us has a personal site sort of a
profile site that's automatically
generated for you when you first run the
browser and that is where we're
publishing these bookmarks so I can jump
over to a new site let's find some
random links on Hacker News here cool
that sounds great let's share that with
the world so you just got out of this
control and make it public and there you
go what just happened I sent over to a
file browser here let's go to my user
profile and my bookmarks I was under
Bloomberg so there it is right there
there's the bookmark that I just
published just as a JSON file on my
profile side I was look at that side
structure again real quick this is
exactly what I was talking about a
moment ago I've got a profile that JSON
with my name and my bio and all that
information about who I'm following and
then underneath the bookmarks file
folder we had these JSON files which are
all my publicly published footmarks
right so hopefully you kind of get an
idea of how these applications work and
how this is what's going on underneath
just files but through that we're able
to build applications that have
you know the kind of features you would
expect out of the web and we're planning
on taking this to the point where first
of all you can have sites that you
publish and sort of like a shared wide
area network file system or you can see
I'm following terrorists so she's
actually in my file system and I can
look at the things she's published and
we're gonna narrow these down by type so
you can have applications or music album
sites and things like that and then
perhaps we can even get into an idea of
helping each other automatically host
the content you published like your
profile and things like that so that we
never need servers at all do you have a
good ten people following you and
contributing bandwidth then by and large
your social network should stay online
by the merit that one and ten are
probably going to have their computer on
right and we think we can take this
pretty far before we really so a we're
probably gonna put in the time line as
well so you could do you know the
equivalent of a tweet inside the browser
and things like that
all right so that wraps up the demo let
me just wrap this all up with a really
really highly biased timeline of the web
both past and future this is kind of
fuzzy but we'll go there look at the 90s
you know what I'm going to call the
academic slash hobbyist web it's kind of
ugly it was cool everybody was into it
and some pretty amazing things happen
Amazon Google for sure happened at that
time and Yahoo was pretty amazing when
it happened too but it was also kind of
I it was a web that only its mother
could love it was you had to be thinking
big to really care about it around 2000
we got kind more web 2.0 right that's
what we had Ajax happened html5 happens
I things get really really
commercialized at this point and it's
actually if you think back on it was
pretty amazing to have slid some of the
new products coming out like I was in
maybe high school and we were printing
out MapQuest Maps and that was just like
the biggest thing in the world it's easy
to forget how exciting those times were
especially because up to 2008 it kind of
slowed down by 2008 we kind of stopped
experimenting as much with social stuff
started be mooring about more about
sharing contents and stuff like
Pinterest and imager and some of the
different
a media platform Scott took off and
really around that time these three guys
won the show and that's why I would
consider this the corporation driven
portion of the web where they are
deciding what we're going to do with the
web platform for the most part not so
much Amazon but definitely Google what
we're going to do with the web platform
what we're going to do with with our
software and of course Facebook sets the
content experience for most people on
the web most people actually just think
of Facebook as the Internet okay so
where's this going to go next I'd love
to have this be 2017 but let's give us
three years of cushion before we can
have this happen where we move away from
the corporation driven mechanism and
into a consumer driven web or perhaps a
little bit more high-minded Liat a more
democratic web because if we're able to
put control over the software and of the
data into the end-user devices that we
should be able to move to a model where
rather than having businesses build off
our applications for us we can get
really open source with it we can let
users build applications from the ground
up change things to fit their needs and
as long as everybody has a fork button
in their browser they should be able to
express their preference for where they
want their web experience to go so that
is where I think we ought to be taking
this both giving people more individual
control over what they're doing but also
at the same time solving some of the
pressing privacy problems that the web
has now and in addition to it being
peer-to-peer I think we can get some
Indian encryption involved and really
lock up some of the deficiencies for how
we share data so that wraps that up you
can check out what we're doing at beaver
browser comm o 8 will probably come out
within the next two months we're not
putting a hard time line on it because
we don't want to make sure we really
like what we're doing so that's gonna be
somewhere the next two months so feel
free to give it a shot and you can find
us online all the time feel free to hit
us on Twitter and we are there to talk
to you so they go very very much for
listening
[Applause]